who am i talking to are you john or are
you
well we're it's a very festive occasion
as we you know premiere
the suicide squad so you know i ask
myself
who i am on a daily basis and the answer
changes sometimes and tonight i'm
dressed up as christopher smith the
peacemaker
i have to tell you that nathan just told
me you have not taken this costume off
in weeks
what i want to know is why is nathan
stalking me he may be right he may be
wrong but how has he kept track of my
whereabouts for weeks
that's a great question we do you want
to make peace with him or will this
start something
uh you know i don't necessarily start it
i just i just take care of the problems
yeah that's a that's a compensation
issue that i'm
still struggling with but that's all
right it's all right what does your
lovely lady think of you wearing this
costume
around well those are conversations we
have together in in our in the privacy
of our own home
has it been worn in the privacy of your
own home i can't confirm or deny that
by the way i got to ask you idris has
said that your freestyling skills
are on another level and i'm wondering
if you can give us a taste
and what what it entails okay so i think
what we have to do is analyze the fact
that idris doesn't listen to enough
hip-hop
no you can't give us even a little bit
oh for him to say that i'm good it
obviously shows he's not
he needs to he needs to listen to more
music he said it was filled with
expletives
um once again you know it was
it was like back in 2004 it was a
completely different person then so
i certainly wasn't this well how much
fun have you had playing this character
the cast is incredible and everybody's
so excited for the movie
well it's a fun movie and i really think
it's um you know we have a bold director
who really wants to change
the way these types of movies are made
and you know everybody's on board i'm
a little bit too on board but uh it's i
think it's a fun experience and the
movie is
fast and light-hearted but with a lot of
emotion as well and i hope everybody
enjoys it
you my friend are hilarious in this
movie and everybody who's been down this
carpet is saying he is so funny his
acting is incredible so how does that
feel
uh surprised because that's i i feel
like no one's ever said that ever
um no uh it's honestly first
if i can thank them for the kind words
and second it's all about environment
and i
i was uh with a lot of experienced and
wonderful people and whenever you get
with people who
force you to rise up to their level it
brings out the best in you and i was
very fortunate to have
james and a great cast to do that